Transcriber: Bassant El-Ghazaly
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
(موسيقى)
فشلت كل محاولاتي في التصالح
مع ذاتي والذين من حولي.
كان لابد أن ينفصل
قلبي عن قاربي،
ولكن المدينة التي جئت منها
كانت تسكن كلاهما
فوصلت للحدود القصوى من حيرتي وهذياني
هنا على هذا الجسد الضعيف الهزيل المنهزم
المحب للحياة،ليست هناك مساحة لأكاذيب الأنا
على هذا القلب، كلنا أخوة، كلنا نفس الإنسان
(تصفيق)
ولهذا، جئتكم
جئت لكي استمع لنفسي من خلالكم
جئت لكي أرى الوجه الثاني للعالم في عيونكم
لم آتي ثائرًا أو فدائيًا أو شاعرًا
أو مغنيًا أو قارعًا للطبول
ولا جئت مبشرًا للخير أو منذرًا للشر
ولا تظنوا أني جئت لأنقد
دينًا أو أدعو لغيره
أينما كنت، دعونا نصلي صلاة
بعدها ندعو إلى الوحدة والألفة والمحبة
والتعايش والسلام.
(تصفيق)
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله
أنا سعيد جدًا بوجودي معكم في هذه الليلة
وأكثر سعادةً بوجودكم.
سنتحدث عن موضوع قد يكون مهمًا جدًا
منذ يوم ولادتنا، ونحن نراه
ونسمع عنه ونعرفه جيدًا
ولكن للأسف، كنا نكتفي دائمًا أننا
نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع
بدون أن نجد له حلول،
نكتفي بأن نقول فقط بأن هذا يحدث.
قبل أن نبدء في الحديث عن موضوعنا، أريد
أن أطلب منكم طلبًا بسيطًا إذا سمحتوا لي
في ثلاثين ثانية فقط،لو ممكن أن يخرج كل
فرد منكم هاتفه ويلتقط صورة “سيلفي” الآن .
لديكم ثلاثون ثانية.
حسنًأ هل ألتقط الجميع الصور؟
الطلب الثاني هو أن كل فرد طلع هنا
-ما شاء الله- وصفقتوا له وحيتوه
وملأتوه بالطاقة وأيضًا كل الأفراد
الذين تحدثوا عن الفريق المنظِم
وطلبوا منكم أن تحيوه،لكن الشيء الوحيد الذي
أريد أن أقوله لكم
أوالطلب الوحيد الذي أطلبه منكم
أنكم الآن تقفوا وتحيوا أنفسكم
رغم الظروف التي تمرون بها
قررتوا أن تتحدوها.
(تصفيق)
حسنًا، تفضلوا
دعونا نتفق أن الناس أصلها واحد
لكن قصصهم في رحلة الحياة مختلفة
ولو فتشنا في قصصهم وكتب ذكرياتهم
سنجد وراء كل قصة
خوف أو حزن أو ألم أو معاناة
ولكن يا ترى هل الطريقة الوحيدة
للتخلص من هذه المعاناة
إننا نأكل ونشرب ونستيقظ و ننام ونعمل
ونتحرك بنفس الطريقة الروتينية.
من أنت ولما تعيش ،هل سبق وسألت نفسك
هذا السؤال البشري البسيط؟
وعندما سألت نفسك، ماذا كانت الإجابة؟
أنا مثلكم مر هذا السؤال عليّ كثيرًا
في حياتي وكنت أحاول دائمًا
أن أسعى لأجد إجابة لهذا السؤال
كنت أجد الإجابة الوحيدة
لهذا السؤال هي النجاح فقط
النجاح بشكل عام، النجاح على صعيد الدراسة
أو على صعيد المهنة،
على صعيد العلاقات
أو حتى على صعيد الموهبة والفن
فأصبحت أبحث في كل النجاحات
لأجد إجابة هذا السؤال
من أنا؟
ولماذا أعيش؟
بدأت بالنجاح الاكاديمي ولكن لم أجد جابة
بدأت بالنجاح على صعيد العلاقات
والصداقات وأيضًا لم أجد الإجابة
وانتقلت مباشرة للزاوية الثالثة
وهي النجاح عن طريق الموهبة والفن
بدأت بكرة القدم ولعبت مع الشباب في الحي
وسجلت هدفًا فقولت حسنًا هذا أنا
أنا افضل فرد يلعب كرة قدم ويسجل أهدافًا
مع الوقت تعودت عليها فتخليت
عن كرة القدم وقولت هذا ليس أنا
فبحثت عن نفسي في شيء ثاني، في فن جديد
تعلمت الرسم، مرة بعد مرة
وجدت الإجابة، هذا أنا،
أنا أفضل من يرسم في هذا البلد
بعد فترة، وجدت أيضا، أنها ليست شخصيتي،
ليس شغفي، فتحولت مباشرة للكتابة
مرة بعد مرة، درس بعد درس،
المضارع، الماضي، الأمر
وهكذا، وجدت أن الإجابة ممكن أن تكون هنا،
أن أجد نفسي في هذا النجاح
من هنا بدأت الرحلة الأصعب،
رحلة التعلم والتغيير والتقبل
والوصول لنتيجة خلال التعب
والمجهود الكبير الذي تبذله هنا
تم كتابة الرواية الأولي والثانية والثالثة،
من هنا جاء السؤال الأصعب والمسئولية الأصعب
أنه كلامك هذا أصبح قدوة ومثلًا لأناس آخرين
فتكون مضطرًا أن تكون مسئول عن كل كلمة
تقولها
حسنًا، بعد فترة مرت أمامي حكمة صغيرة،
استوقفتني كثيرًا
تقول، الصالحون يبنون أنفسهم
والمصلحون يبنون الأمم
ومن هنا فهمت أنني أتحول من شخص صالح
لشخص مصلح، كيف يمكنني أن أبني الأمم
وكيف يمكنني أن أغير في أمتي لأنني أحسست
أن هذه رسالتي التي جئت من أجلها للوجود
ليس أنا فقط، وأنتم أيضا
ماذا يمكن أن أقدم للأمم؟
بالفعل، بدأت في البحث عن إجابة لهذا السؤال
حتى تم إنشاء مؤسسة
هذه المؤسسة تضم الموهوبين،
تدعم وتطور وتحفز وتدرس
الموهبة بكل أنواعها وبكل تفاصيلها
الموهبة هذه الآن وأنا أقف على المنصة
المؤسسة هذه الآن وأنا أقف على المنصة
تضم أكثر من خمسين ألف موهبة تتعلم وتتدرب
لتصل لهدفها، من هناك أقدر أن أقول لكم
أنه تم تنظيم أكثر من معرض لهذه المؤسسة
في المعرض الثاني، قررنا أن أن يعكس المعرض
الهويات الختلفة للسودان والقبائل المختلفة
والشعوب المختلفة للسودان، حتي عندما نكون
في مكان ممكن أن نجهل المكان الآخر
لأن هذه الأرض من حقنا جمعيا، يجب أن نعرف
كل شبر منها ليس مليون ميل
نحن نعرف المليون ميل ملك لمن
(تصفيق)
تم تنظيم المعرض وتم تسميته ب”استاد وطن“
ولأن الميلون ميل من حقنا جميعًا، وانا أقف
على المنصة على استعداد
في نيالا، أن ننظم معرض يعكس الهويات
المختلفة لكل السودان ويسمى
”ولاية نيالا“
(تصفيق)
حسنًا، حتى نصل إلى هذه المرحلة
نحن بحاجة إلى أمرين
نحن بحاجة إلى التصالح والسلام.
حسنًا، كيف يمكنني أن أصل إلى التصالح؟
التصالح في معناه أنه أتقبل كل شيء وعكسه،
وأتقبل الفطرة التي جئت بها إلى الوجود
أن طبيعتك تتضمن كل شعور وعكسه،
بها كل شيء وضده
بها فرح وحزن، بها انفعالات وهدوء
والكون مبني على أساس هذه الفطرة
مخلوق بهذه الفطرة، يوجد ليل ونهار
وبرد وصيف.
وحتى تصل لمرحلة التصالح تلك،
يجب أن تتقبل كل شعور بك وضده
ولا تحاول أن تغير أمر بك بالإكراه، لأنه
طالما تحاول أن تغير أمر بك بالإكراه
ولم يتغير، ستظل عائشًا في حالة صراع داخلي
وطالما أنت في صراع داخلي،
فلن تكون قادرًا على الإنتاج
لن تكون شخصًا مصلحًا ولا شحصًا صالحًا،
ستكون شخصًا عائشًا دائما في حالة صراع فقط
حسنًا، سنتجه للنقطة الثانية الخاصة
بالسلام،هل تعلمون ما هي مشكلتنا في الحياة؟
مشكلتنا في أمرين،
الأمر الأول نعيش دائمًا في دور الضحية
ونكتفي بقول أن الآخرين تسببوا في ذلك
مع أن السؤال الصحيح كان من المفترض أن يكون
إذا كان يجب أن أفعل عندما تعرضت لهذا؟
فأنت بحاجة للإجابة على هذا السؤال
بدلًا من أن تعيش في دور الضحية
حتى نتكلم عن السلام بصورته العامة، قيل
قديمًا كلمة جميلة جدًا من أحد المتحدثين
قال أن السلام يبدأ منك، قبل أن
تقول أننا يجب أن نصل للسلام
سِل نفسك هذا السؤال،
ماذا فعلت أنت من أجل هذا السلام؟
ماذا غيرت في هذا المجتمع
وهذه الأمة من أجل تحقيق السلام
الذي تدعو له في كل مكان، وتقول
أنك تريده وأننا جمعيًا نريده وسنصل إليه؟
أنت لن تصل طالما أنك تقول أنك
الشخص الوحيد الذي يملك هذه اللحظة
وانك الشخص الوحيد الذي يملك هذا القرار
طالما أنك تملك هذه اللحظة وهذا القرار،
فالأفضل أن تنهض وتنتفض
وتبدء رحلتك لأن الحياة أصبحت صعبة،
وجميعنا نعترف بهذا الأمر
نحن بحاجة إلى أناس صادقين في حياتنا
قادرين أن يغيروا فينا وفي المجتمع
لأن في هذه اللحظة الضائعة
وأنت تقول أننا نريد السلام
سيأتي أولادك ويجدونك في
نفس الموقع وتقول نفس الكلام
لأنك لم تستغل هذه اللحظة، فبدلًا من أن
تعمل، اكتفيت بأن تقول وتعيش في دور الضحية
وأن الآخرين فعلوا ذلك بنا
وبالمناسبة، الفكرة ليست فقط
أننا نريد أن نصل للسلام الكبير
وأننا نتعايش معًا وأن نكون متحابين وإخوة
الفكرة تبدء من هنا، بجانبك الكثير من
المهملات، لو أخرجتها ووضعتها في السلة
أنت هكذا ساعدت في نشر السلام
و تبني مجمتع مصلح، قادر علي العيش
في حب وألفة ورحمة ووفرة
حسنًا، لماذا لا يتحقق السلام في حياتنا؟
وذلك لسببين:
السبب الأول هو التسامح
نحن في حاجة أن نعيش متسامحين
هل تعلموا ماذا نحن نشبه؟ قلوبنا مثل الكوب
امتلأ ذلك الكوب من كثرة
المواقف التي مر بها في حياته
امتلأ مواقف سلبية وجارحة
ومواقف كبيرة بالنسبة لنا
الأصح أن نفرغ تلك الرواسب
الموجودة بالداخل لنبدء وننطلق
أنت تستيقظ كل صباح وتقول أنا سأنطلق
ولكن تشعر بأن أحدًا ما يسحبك للخلف
ذلك الشحص الذي يسحبك للخلف
هي المواقف المتبقية في حياتك
التي لا تقدر أن تسامح فيها لتبدء كشخص جديد
قادر على الوصول إلى كل شيء يتمنى تحقيقه.
هل تعلموا عندما قالوا قديمًا
فلان محظوظ وفلان محظوظ؟
لا يوجد شخص بذاته محظوظ،
أي شخص في هذه القاعة الآن
وعنده فرصة في الوقت الحاضر
الذي أتحدث عنه، فهو محظوظ
لأن الشخص الوحيد الغير محظوظ هو الذي
لا يملك تلك اللحظة، وهم الأفراد الميتون.
هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الغير محظوظين،
أنت الشخص الوحيد المحظوظ،
لأنك لديك الفرصة لتبدء وتقرر
وأنك تقول” أنا قادر أني أصل
إلى كل شيء أتمناه،
أنا قادر أن أكون الأفضل دائمًا،
أنا قادر على المساعدة في تحقيق السلام.”
السلام هو أن أحبك وأن تحبني مثلما أكون
حتى لو كانت فكرتي مختلفة معك،
حتى لو كان معتقدي مختلف معك،
حتى لو كانت مشاعري مختلفة مع مشاعرك،
المهم أن تتقبلني وتحبني كما أنا
وأنا يجب أن أتقبلك وأحبك كما أنت
لأن أنا وأنت يجمعنا احتياج واحد،
هو احتياج الحياة.
فهذه الحياه ليست من حقك وحدك
وليست من حقي وحدي.
أنا وأنت وكل شيء موجود في
هذا الكون شركاء في هذه الحياة
من المفترض أن نعرف هذا الاحتياج جيدًا،
ونحترم هذا الحق لأي شخص.
أبدء أنت.
الأمر الثاني الذي نحتاجه
لتحقيق السلام هو الرحمة.
الرحمة الرحمة.
الرحمة هي أن تسامح، الرحمة هي
أن ترى الله فى كل خطواتك،
وفى كل شخص أمامك.
الرحمة هي أن تساعد الشخص الضعيف العاجز
بدلًا من أن تعايره وتجعل الناس ينظرون إليه
وعندما يأتي دورك وتكون في نفس موقفه،
تقول ” أنا لم أجد من يساعدني”
أنت لم تجد أحد يساعدك لأنك انتزعت
الرحمة التي من المفترض أن تكون بداخلك.
أنت لم تصل إلى التعايش السلمي الذي قضيت
عمرك وأنت تقول أنك تريد الوصول إليه.
لأنك لم تبدء
حتى تصل لابد أن تبدء أنت
الكون كله عبارة عن انعكاس
لصورتك الذاتية لهذا الكون.
كيف ترى هذا الكون، حسب
نظرتك للكون ستجد هذه الحقيقة
قد طلبت منكم من قبل التقاط
صورة“سيلفي“، أليس كذلك؟
ابقوا على علم بأن اللحظة التي التقطوا بها
الصورة هي اللحظة الوحيدة الحقيقية بحياتكم
وأن الشخص صاحب الصورة في هاتفكم
هو الشخص الوحيد الحقيقي
هذا الشخص وهذه الصورة هي الصورة الوحيدة
منك والتي إذا قدرت على الوصول لأفضل نسخة
وتعايشت وأحبت الناس
وقدمت للناس ولو أبسط شيء
ولو كلمة، فأنت قادر على التغيير
لذلك، فإنك متى ما رسمت لوحة
أو كتبت قصيدة
فإنك غيرت العالم
لن تغيره تمامًا، ولكن قد غيرته
فصار أجمل بمقدر لوحة،
وصار مستحقًا أن نقاتل من
أجله أكثر ولو بمقدار لوحة
وهذا معنى آخر لذلك القول
" أرضًا أعيدت ولو لثانية،
جمالًا أعيد ولو بقدر لوحة،
أو بيت شعرًا،
أو وقفة عز لأعزل
أمام دبابة تهابه ولا يهابها
(تصفيق)
شكرًا لكم